je ne connaissais pas du tout et
l'exercice est arrivé comme ça il m'a
dit d'imiter donc avec naulleau qui est
un livreur
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est nouveau ça tu la fais juste pour
la robe un nom mais parce que j'avais
fait un petit moment parce que
j'aimerais ça mignon j'adore cadeau de
tatouages
oui mais voilà c'est un pistolet dans le
coup ensuite des ailes d'ange et ses
labos c'est la date de naissance de ma
grand-mère d'ailleurs que j'embrasse
elle s'est fait mal aux eaux
elle nous regarde je t'aime allez allez
donc l année en 1700 riber l'ont emmené
137 est bas et en heure non non non et
non et sur qu'est steve bourricot new
way sas a énormément fait réagir est ce
que ça vous a choqué ou pas est sur le
flanc alors énorme alors derrière je
voulais juste vous dire cette séquence à
fait normal a fait énormément réagir
notamment le sait pas mais même si c'est
un poisson dans l'eau chaude et jacuzzi
un des points ce soir
honnêtement oui moi tout ce qui touche
aux animaux je suis jamais deux jolies
dépend énormément la fondation bardot
[Rires]
[Musique]
rendu des animaux mais c'est des
crustacés
les poissons évidence les brestois
s'étaient crabes
non mais peu importe pourquoi on serait
moins triste pour des poissons que pour
un mouton
je veux dire ce sont des animaux sont
des êtres vivants chose aux animaux je
suis pas bien et je défends 200000
espace nabila ben ouais ouais mais ce
qu'il dit ils ont même pas de sens les
poissons attentes à la fois glauque
comme j'étais à cannes on m'a dit que ma
robe
elle me faisait penser à elle mérite à
renault
oh les gars et elle avait le print web
mais a manqué ce n'est pas une chanteuse
mais rennes à l'actrice exactement je ne
connaissais pas du tout et l'exercice
est arrivé comme ça il m'a dit d'imiter
donc avec naulleau qui est un libraire
[Rires]
j'adore j'adore pour l'annuler en fait
j'avais décrit au hb également été deux
comme balla 3 de crayon hb et e
qu'est-ce que je n'ai pas d'ego sont
5000 euros la route ça moi je prends la
robe j'ai acheté un appartement à poil
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai qu'à la taille de keddy la
robe faisait juste de sérieux
[Musique]